okay you got that yummy yummy where'd he
come up with that from yummy yummy
that's good that yummy yummy such a bang
and you know what's weird
after that song came out Kylie Jenner
posted a pic and a caption was yummy and
I'm thinking Bugatti B but daddy Biebs
yeah Global global my age sets trends he
does that's that tune yummy yeah well
you know what's funny if you put sign in
you can say anything in a song and
[ __ ] like it it sounds good bye yummy
yummy if I wrote to a thing so baby look
like got a yummy you [ __ ] disgusting
bastard
you got a yummy yummy gonna yum yum
please yummy looking delicious yummy
yummy they're so hideous [ __ ]
that's funny run yeah hit me bro you
know I yeah I actually think I actually
think I might have to start every
episode just get you off my chest
yeah because sometimes I get I don't
like to talk about negative stuff but
sometimes it builds up on me yeah and
gets me stressed and I just need to vent
it my peeve at the minute is how do I
describe it is like it's like excuses so
you say you want to do something we
probably talked about the book those
times before but say you want to do
something or you like doing something
you say you're gonna do something and
then when you ain't done it yeah it's
just like I don't
it's not necessarily the excuses right I
don't like when people don't own [ __ ]
yeah so save for example I tell you I'm
gonna Jim I'm gonna oh I want to go Jim
I want to go Jim mmm and you're like all
right calm go Jim and then the next time
we talk yellow how did you go Jim and
I'm like now you know what I wanted to
bar this this this happen despite
raining and this rather than me just
being like
bro I wanted to go gym I looked outside
it's [ __ ] raining I was i [ __ ] that I
want to stay inside I ain't going no one
says that yeah it's always something
this is something it is always an excuse
or justification for what you want to do
something yeah and it just annoys me
like just do it if you actually want to
do it just do just do it and if you
haven't done it then you didn't want to
do it yeah and it's just like don't ever
say I want to do something you can't
like you couldn't do it just do it just
do it just [ __ ] do it
probably [ __ ] pisses me off but yes
pretty much run over I just want to get
off my get off your Jessica Lee I can
tell hmm you know um that's thing about
you know when obviously I always say
like I can't talk to girls mm-hmm and
like all just people a lot of the time
mm-hmm and like I get nervous and I
don't know what to say
mm-hmm and like I stutter on a stumble
and all these things have I ever told
you the story ever actually how that
started I don't think so about why I can
talk to girls
or why I get what not nicely worried but
yeah why can't alter girls marry if you
say the story I might remember but I
don't think spam it only just reminded
myself like a day or two ago of how it
actually started check this so I was a
quiet kid anyway and [ __ ] [ __ ]
he actually distance to this [ __ ] so I
hope you [ __ ] is it I was seeing how
old what year was I I must have been
like thief no probably like 16 yeah and
hmm there was a girl so basically I
lived on the other side of town so I
didn't live near my school I lived near
another school yeah so I used to walk it
was like a mile or two away nice to walk
home every day but I literally lived on
the doorstep of his other school right
okay I knows this girl didn't know her
name didn't know anything about her but
she would walk past my house every day
mmm and fact she was so buff yeah I
later found out her name was Lauren she
was so buff she was just like the
buffest girl yeah you've ever seen yeah
Oh at the time I had ever seen I was and
you know
obviously when you're a kid you build
stuff up in your head but even not even
when your key probably still do it now
side like when you see someone all the
time you don't know them
beeping they're buff you build this this
thing about because you don't know
anything about you build this like crazy
imagination about what there must be
like and like all this stuff so I was
Casper and this went on for years before
because she was a year I think she was a
year older so literally from year 7 all
the way to like year 1011 I would see
her every single day walking past my
house and I was obsessed of her yeah so
basically I went into 6 4 now and I went
to the sixth form that my school was
running so my sis forms I see a test in
my school yeah yeah secondary sources a
form was all about the same thing and
there was a few there was a sports class
that there was a sports class that I
think it was there was a reason why we
had to go to a different school so
basically had to go to a different six
forum to do this specific sports class
that we wanted to do right I think it
was like a more advanced a level for
sports than the one that my sixth one
was doing so they offered to let us go
to a different six forum to do it
coincidentally it was the sixth form of
the other school on the other side of
town I thought I would live I live near
right so me my boy John who does the guy
that was on episode three yeah the
graphic designer me him and another one
of our boys called Tyrone
Alwyn there right so a few days we would
go there mm-hmm lo and behold the girl
she was a year older than us she was
like in that sixth form as well yeah so
now I've seen her and I'm like ah [ __ ]
yeah um I'm excited but I'm scared at
the same time so we're going there a few
months in everything's cool and I must
have told the story to my boy John I'll
bow for them we'll walk him back to our
six one one day and I was like ah
there's this girl that goes to sixth
form I don't know if you've seen her
she's banging and I've literally seen it
every day since I was in year 7 and like
I'm in love like she's the love of my
life yeah like um and he's our which one
is it which one is it so the next day I
showed him
he's like yeah yeah she's nice she's
nice just like that and I was like cool
so next time we're walking home now
and we see her my man is like chapter
how the [ __ ] am I gonna say no this is
the fantasy girl you don't talk to the
fantasy you just leave it leave it
this is I never see you again and then I
just think of what could have been here
so I'm right I ain't talking to her he's
a buff come on big man talk to her and
then obviously same thing man's like
your [ __ ] if you don't talk to us and
just talk to her and then obviously
what's gonna happen is you're not gonna
talk to her
we're gonna go back and I'm just gonna
have to tell or demandin that you
couldn't talk to her yeah all right
cause then I'm gonna have to [ __ ]
talk to her
little did I know so obviously I'm 16 I
didn't know about talking to girls I
don't know you're supposed to go in with
something to say yeah and I'm like cool
so I jog over I'm like oh sorry sorry
excuse me and she turns around and she's
like hey I literally froze cuz I just
realized that I don't know what I'm
supposed to be saying and I was like hi
she goes hi I'm James she was so cool
she didn't even tell me her name she was
that okay and obviously she's on the
spot thinking what the [ __ ] is this yeah
and then I'm like cool and then in my
head I'm like well obviously I can't
tell her that I just see her everyday
and like I love her like I can't set it
up so like what am I supposed to say
yeah yeah yeah and then broke my I'm
freezing I'm freezing this time and I'm
sweating I'm thinking what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to say cuz like is it a
situation where I'm supposed to stand
here talk to her for half an hour is it
a situation what I supposed to just
introduce myself and leave like I didn't
have a game plan here I've never spoken
to a girl like moving to her before
whatever I don't even know if I am
moving to it like I yeah brother
I'm panicking I'm panicking now you're
measuring imma [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then I was like cool I know this is
weird I just really I saw you want to
introduce myself I have done that now
some gotta go and she was like okay and
then I left and then
I was mortified mortified so
saunders-roe that's stage one so it's
that stage one mortified I don't ever
want to see you again and I've like just
embarrassing myself and yeah so that
happened I'm over it
a couple months later there's like it
must have been like an interview party
or something and it was for their sixth
form but we were invited to go so yeah
we went down there it was the three of
us again me John Tyrone and all the
friends that would met at this new sixth
form and all that stuff's over there
Gillian having a good time and she's
there mm-hmm so my boy John again goes
chat to work and I'm like your mom I'm
not that simple just that's over you
granny you can tell the man what you
need to tell them cuz I ain't gonna talk
to her again and I was like all right
cool left it about an hour half an hour
later my my scum but we've had a couple
drinks everyone's having a good time
my mic comes over and minds like brav
you'll never [ __ ] guess what
and I was out what he's like I was at
the bar that girl that you love it was
there started talking to her and she
made reference to you and I'm like what
did she say if she was that ah she said
that you were qu ran up to her the other
day and you were like embarrass and all
that yeah yeah and then like she said
you're nice so she said like you should
go asking for a dance later like when
you get a chance and I'm like you ought
the best friend anyone's ever had
are you [ __ ] winding me up miles I
promise we're like yeah I couldn't
believe it and I was like gasps gasps
man sixteen I found the love of my life
less I was a problem
I'm bar yeah would you mean my [ __ ] up
and she's still down yeah I'm I'm bought
for certified buff yeah I've grown into
my teeth and everything's fine so that
happens and now I'm like like psyching
myself up so like half an hour goes by
haven't done it hour goes by I haven't
done we probably like an hour left
before this thing yeah yeah and I'm like
[ __ ]
and I'm he's like Brookfield gonna have
to go and do it because the things about
to close and then you're gonna lose your
chance and I'm like okay cool let me go
finish my drinking I'm right let me go
rolled up to her again she sees me she
smiles hmm I'm like hi she's like hi and
then I was like can I get that dance now
fam she said what give you a [ __ ] to
give it up I could give it she was like
what are you one about dance and I was
found I looked back my mouth was my man
was on his hands and knees crying with
laughter and my heart was in my throat
[Laughter]
I can see it like it was yesterday I'm
like oh my god and then uh I like I had
to improvise in it and now she was like
dance were you in about and I was like
nothing nothing nothing
don't worry like don't worry about him
talk about she was like eh you the guy
that came out to me the other day yeah
and I was like yeah and she was like
what was that about
no I I don't know she goes all of a
sudden she switched it and she was like
how old are you this is go from bad to
worse this is getting worse and worse
and I was like I'm 16 and she was like
oh well I'm 18 I never see as a kid yeah
six-year-old boy an 18 year old girl -
never mix it that's a different
generation yeah yeah yeah okay and then
she was like so what did you want like
what did you want mmm and I was a
[Music]
nothing it's just okay bye
I was like bye and then I walk back and
from that day phone
that day still haunts me and that's why
I don't talk to go that's why I don't
talk to ghosts oh my god
mortifying mods for my so-called friend
is the reason I don't talk to ghosts to
think I had him on the podcast I should
have brought that up the [ __ ] bastard
funny fam it's the worst experience ever
these girls don't know how hard it is
embarrassing that how embarrassing is
that embarrassing that's the most
embarrassed I think that's the most
embarrassing that's ever happened to me
that's embarrassing
fam it was horrible it was [ __ ]
horrible
I hated it I hate every second of it
[ __ ] that's embarrassing
do you know why I will never forgive you
for do you know I'll never forgive you
for
remember back in uni this was probably
third year I don't know thank you no
third you were second year no was it uni
was it uni
no I must have been I don't know I don't
know when it was but anyway it was big
booty Judy until despair I was after you
need her off that was that was me I
don't even know my name I thought my
real name but for reference so that was
a few years below us in Union she was a
white girl but she had the thickest
awesome thickest tits I thought it was a
joke buddy was an absolute joke and me
and REM were down we were down down down
down so it was kind of like see you can
get a first kind of thing
so obviously REM was a lot more
courageous when it came to women back in
new name he was I was a little [ __ ] or
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] or when it came
to women and I don't know how I had
girlfriends because I was a little [ __ ]
or anyway so rambling up to her they
were talking talking talking and then it
was at like um it was at the hub there
was a sum function ting some dancing a
Carmen bar she gave him a fake number
but he didn't know was a fake number
until he started text in it know her
hold it was a number that she had given
another Brit at that same shoobs said
Ben man
and each other thinking both of them
were the girl so she played both of them
they've they they were texting each
other about a link bro he was so excited
when he got the text back I wish you
were there when he got the text back
like hi babe
of course I remember you like I said I
can't remember but it was literally like
oh hi babe of course I remember you from
last night yeah my man stood up in the
living room yeah and spied dougie in I
must like she's down o kumi babe course
she remembers me good is much dougie in
and yeah I think they agreed to meet mmm
that night yeah like that and then we
were insane spring yeah we were in
Sainsbury's we were walking through the
aisles and he stopped he lived on his
phone I was like Rob I don't think this
is Judy what happened how did they clock
it I can't remember something like this
the guy on the other line said something
that resonated with what a man would say
yeah something like that
yeah or like something like did you have
fun with your girls or some something
along that line those lines and then
obviously Bren was like go go yeah and
he was like I don't think this is Judy
yeah Oh ever and then I think he replied
like is this her name's Melissa and that
was so bad in bru name was he's like is
this is this Melissa she goes or he goes
oh he goes no this is Javon from last
night
REM we're not and they said beefing
leaving each other yeah man was like
Jeff Van ruff did you not read the first
text I said hi babies Erin another I had
it saved as Melissa from I wasn't
reading the fashion sense
and this I can angry so that was catfish
number one that was catfish number one
then my turn rolled around cuz I never
had I don't think I had a number I don't
even know how when about maybe I spoke
to her and gave her my number
yeah but she never mess with me anything
so it was probably a year later
it must have because we were done with
uni we were done we were done with you I
remember sitting on the edge of my bed
and I get a message saying hey babies I
don't know if you remember me but my
name is Melissa you moved to me last
year blah blah just checking to make
sure you cool some [ __ ] story like
that
I remember screen showing it sending it
to this [ __ ] and being gassed
absolutely gassed I replied back saying
yeah of course I remember you or this
rare tear tear tear and then I think how
did he expose me how did I expose you
how do you expose the thing cuz you I
didn't realize until you Tommy wasn't I
think I remember was now I remember how
exposed but that I fish to say it you
can say okay so the guy you were seeing
at the time yeah messaged me laughing
[ __ ] laughing I was like no she
referenced the message like what the
[ __ ] you guys like what the [ __ ] is
going on and then I think I messaged you
saying why is why is this girl messaging
me read her and then you started
laughing
you slide [ __ ] laugh about what the
[ __ ] is going on what is actually going
on and he's like ah it's [ __ ] this
isn't Melissa this is so-and-so that I'm
seeing my blood I was on the edge of my
bed and you know when vain such as in
your head I had never been so betrayed
in my life
so you know what's funny I don't know
what possessed me to do even to do that
neither do i but it was [ __ ] funny
it was [ __ ] funny thing I knew she
would be the one girl yeah that like you
would ignore logic for yeah there should
be the one go of that like you wouldn't
you'd be too gas to be suspicious yeah
that's how I know you know me because I
know for a fact you said to the guy at
the time that you were seeing that
please message few yet cuz I know he's
gonna screenshot and send it to me
that's how I know this prick knows me
because that's exactly what I [ __ ] did
and I was just playin his hands from
there it was so annoying it was [ __ ]
funny I [ __ ] hated that day heard of
Ames in my head when I found out I
wasn't her she would the thing is I
don't even know her I remember she was
buff but her body it was a joke the body
was absolutely fought for her age she
must be pregnant now she must be
pregnant or have a kid of course because
no man slit her body was disgraceful but
like the calm how that's how often does
she get moved to to start thinking like
right
tonight I'm gonna play a game with it
yeah cuz I already know at least two
[ __ ] are gonna ask me for my
number yeah yeah every night she goes
every night it happens so tonight's the
night I'm gonna do like us whips what
yeah and then see what and the fingers
as well she did this whole number swap
mmm and she has no idea what happened
the repercussions nothing she went about
her [ __ ] day she slept like a baby
that night after spider I have to
sputter
I have to sputter because that's a one
thinking bro she didn't give a flying
[ __ ] about the repercussions of it but
what's mad is like if let's say I was
airing in that situation when asking her
for her number obviously gave her she
gave Reb my man's other number so she
must have looked through a phone and
then typed in his number in her in REMS
phone but these times everyone knows
their number of head that's the thing
you know I mean it was it was a team
what it was what what it was was that
she said what was it so when the Javan I
asked her first for what was it no no no
that was it so obviously the Javan guy
came to her mm-hmm and said can I have
your number and she would have said no
you can't have my number but give me
your number and I'll message you yeah
yeah
and then obviously when REM came to her
he said can I have my number yeah she's
like course she can
she probably yeah everyone has a number
of him but I'm assuming she said I've
got new phone or what she he probably
didn't give a [ __ ] ever [ __ ] he vote
leaders for guests in a moment yeah yeah
gassed and that's it
but the [ __ ] bollocks of it I want to
know if it was premeditated from wait
before it even happened yeah or if she
said like give me your number to the guy
like giving your number and whatever
which like she always says mmm and then
thought when it Remz walking over to her
ask him for it yeah [ __ ] it let me give
him this number that's so genius
that's calculated you have to get moved
to so often yeah to do that so often
that is crazy and I don't know what she
gets move to so I know she got me too
all the time
her figure was disgraceful she got moved
to all the [ __ ] time every single
time that's all I ever saw of her if I
ever saw it was her get him again move
to yeah Jesus I hate to be a curvaceous
female off core I hate it yeah of course
[ __ ]
everywhere you go if you go to a beach
you're [ __ ] of course if you go on
holiday or [ __ ]
of course it's at a gym you're [ __ ]
that's the thing as well cuz like
obviously another reason that I don't
really talk to girls is because you see
so many of them just give like immediate
dismissal
yeah immediate intense hang it yeah and
like to me that's extremely rude yeah
and I don't want to put myself through
that that's the one that's embarrassing
and it's rude so I don't put myself for
it but same time like yeah they must go
through it so much that it's just like
it's just standard like they can't they
can't keep up the polite persona anymore
anymore they don't give a [ __ ] you then
it yes just like [ __ ] hell Lima like
yeah that's crazy
doofy that's crazy because guys do not
experience that and they just do not
just don't we dive far you don't get
spoken to like we don't get moved to
nothing it just doesn't happen it
doesn't happen and you get me anyway if
you get
move to like it's once maybe in a night
mom-mom once like if it happens twice
then Jesus Christ you're looking fresh
night and day yeah yeah sightings in the
air sex in the air like it just doesn't
happen yeah so like I would never cuz
I've spoken to girls and they've went
out like we've had these discussions
about like nights out and like talking
to girls I don't talk to girls
and they say like yeah I don't ever talk
to guys and I'm like why and they're
like what I just I don't want to get I
projected and stuff and I was like
brother like or I don't want them to be
rude to me or whatever I'm like that's
never gonna happen that is never ever
ever ever ever gonna happen yeah and
even if you did get rejected the guy
that's rejected in you isn't a girl he
doesn't get moved to 11 times a day so
he's not gonna be dismissive he's gonna
entertain it like he's gonna be polite
to you yeah and he's gonna talk to you
and stuff like that so like it's not
gonna be a rejection ting like what guys
go through guys get the worst guys just
get like a oh yeah and then just walk or
they but his friend she's cha the friend
I hate the boys friend the [ __ ] ugly
friend imagine knowing you're the ugly
friend and that's your job for the night
that's your job [ __ ]
like imagine do they do they have that
conversation before end does that babe
obviously we know I'm gonna get moved to
tonight
I can't be asked for it I need you in
there to tell Dee's man not to fall
because they're not gonna move to you
yeah so you need to be there to tell
them no oh god I [ __ ] hate the buzzer
and everyone has the best friend I've
[ __ ] hated the butters friend it's so
jarring oh I'd hate to know on the bus
friend as well I'd hate to [ __ ] on
the bus right yeah I thought you be it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was thinking as well
because this this this is like similar
ish you know when I said we were
watching whatever the [ __ ] it was
yesterday si or whatever last night and
I said like how do you get the part for
like door open and number three and all
you do is shake your head in clothes
like how do you audition for that like
when you're an actor or actress or
whatever
and you're looking for roles and you
know when you see someone who's cast as
like literally like the fattest ugliest
person do you look at that and think
that's me I think I can get that role
how [ __ ] depressing is that because
there are people that are like renowned
for playing roles that are just like fan
ugly just like you're the fan ugly guy
that's you that stain your leg kind of
thing and it's like you'll never be
anything else and you are that role and
there's how [ __ ] depressing is that
some people have getting a paycheck for
it they're getting paid yeah of course
that's the thing but that's terrible for
your self-esteem I know they've probably
they're probably long gone past that not
long ago pastor self-efficacy had
self-esteem it's true they're just out
here trying to make that gwap with their
flat body oh I've seen like I've heard
like interviews and stuff like that
where they'll say like to that too like
he might say oh I want to lose some
weight I want to go gym stuff like that
and then like the casting directors and
stuff like don't no way we need you how
you are now [ __ ] [ __ ] off that's [ __ ]
off especially if they're like part of a
franchise or if they're like in a TV
series and they've like halfway through
the season and then you want to start
like now you lose weight that doctor
says I'm gonna dive like that's my bro
he's actually crazy oh yeah I hate that
to be me it's funny oh Jesus I'm so
tired I don't even know why today just
in jano today ya know in general that
sounds depressing but no I don't even
know why my for because of the food mmm
and the shower afterwards it felt good
showers are amazing anyone who [ __ ]
with buff doesn't [ __ ] when he found I I
hate I caught remember last time I take
it off like it when I say bye I mean
like getting in the top and Lane and
that's like I might over my kid I don't
need a bobble off for no reason cuz
give me a shower any day of the week was
a million times bow
and the things are above it just gets
colder so the longer you're in it the
worse it is the dirt your it gets and
then the dirt year it gets why am I
having a bah-bah-bah he won explain to
me why are you mine having bubble baths
cos what's the bubble bobs that's funny
Bravo [ __ ] hate boss oh I used to get
angry I remember when I was younger when
I would be sick I've got a hangover or
from ill or whatever and my mum would be
there just like why don't you run
yourself a nice bar for me
shut up no I've had six hours they ain't
making me feel bad yeah the bars has got
him even feel a million times worse I
hate baths [ __ ] hate bars and anyone
who takes above preaches for the bar I
know they do creatures and they'll barf
anywhere they'll barf in any [ __ ] tub
nah hotel tubs also owes fair enough it
sees their own man
east of their own indeed you each to
their own indeed but remember when we
tried Mandy oh my god I had half a
crystal of Mandy oh my good god
that was an experience shapes oh you're
you're like senses I know our cute for
it they're ready for it like mine I had
this smart yeah I'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright this much I had this much was we
supposed to spoil it I don't know cuz
fam tell the truth this is what happened
for me this is actually what happened I
think I pretended to be high for the
most of the life because I had what like
one Rock which was like miniscule yeah
tiny tiny tiny thing so to put it in
context we went on holiday a few of the
fellows decided we wanted The Hangover
experience we wanted the whole Shabbat
so we needed to secure some recreational
drugs we secured said recognitions right
and then find those huddled round in
this shitty little big garden all right
let's do this guy's and we're all
nervous I'm like hey this is it none of
us have done it
none of us has done it before then one
of our friends who was there had done it
before and he's like yeah yeah this is
the real [ __ ] this is this is the real
clean [ __ ]
this is pharmaceutical grade and I'm
like gasps all right cool so bearing in
mind we've got like I didn't even know
how to my juggling goes off we've got
like a portion for one person yeah split
between four yeah so alright okay we're
gonna have to microdose this [ __ ] so
everyone gets like one or two little
crystals each and then we snorted it so
everyone snorted it and then lo and
behold everyone gets their own level of
my my crystal I thought that's not a tit
right got stuck in my nose hairs for the
whole night no way for the whole night
and there's me like I'm in a chance I'm
seeing strobe lighting oh yeah I think
is I think it's not good I think is
kicked in and when we were leaving when
we were leaving
I literally something happened and I
just I just sniffed and then it felt it
snapped the back of my throat
no where's that I was a ways that I was
like when I said I think I said to
someone when you snorted the rock did it
like lick you in your back ear throat
and sting and he was like yeah this was
supposed to happen and I was thinking oh
no oh my god oh my god he's only just
hit me now is liddie I've only just
taken it now he's been in my nostril
hairs for six hours he's only just hit
me now and then I didn't even know I
went to obviously we went home went to
bed so I didn't really get anything I
just had a placebo the whole night
my experience was very different because
very different cuz so i snowed mine and
I was thinking yeah I'm not feeling
anything let me grab a bit more and I
think I snorted a bit more and up like
put some in my gums as well and started
licking off the night went on the night
went on and I was fine
throughout the tenure of the club but
it's when we left it's like walking home
they met those American girls yes let me
started talking talking talking more you
guys started talking that's when it hit
me I couldn't [ __ ] speak my I didn't
even cuz I don't remember getting a buzz
all our members having to calm down
yeah and I couldn't [ __ ] speak mundum
don't do drugs bro literally don't do it
I couldn't [ __ ] speak all I remember
was I was drooling James
I was just Drew and I was like all I
remember saying is I want to [ __ ] go
home
you know we're trying to Americans for
days cuz that was [ __ ] funny
you know what the funniest thing is the
dog in you from the dog in you you
couldn't form a sentence gonna help you
were there and they go this is America
girls talking and then she mentioned her
Instagram name it wasn't even me that
clocked it it was Toby that clock dear
Toby went to add her on Instagram and he
said followed by free honey you're there
in the corner in silence can't speak and
you just added which is honey 3 crap he
didn't even contribute to the
conversation I remember one pic she was
wearing one blue like sundress ting and
a bat he was a massive massive [ __ ] she
looked good good good I went home I
threw up a shot and a showered I wake up
fresh oh my dad's fresh oh you know I'm
so angry about that holiday why I didn't
[ __ ] get any sleep yeah and to be
fair the whole my problem is is I get
excited about [ __ ] for the sake of
getting excited I get anyone could get
me excited so I need to like my I'm old
now firm I'm 28
and a lobbying thing that's not old my
joints no it's old yeah so like I need
my Annie I need to give my body the the
rest and respect it deserves firm in my
head on the way there I'm like cool game
plan we're in IB fur we're gonna be busy
mmm we might be getting in at 6:00 7:00
in the morning I need to get my [ __ ]
sleep
we're not gonna be doing [ __ ] in the day
so I need to get my sleep and then I can
carry on next day fam when obviously we
got there
Toby surprised us or me and he's talking
the most Mack yeah like ladies guys I'm
only here for two days I sleep [ __ ]
I'm not [ __ ] sleeping I'm just going
all out and there's me like yes that's
exactly what I'm doing I'm gonna [ __ ]
sleep yeah let's go crazy yeah I needed
to sleep because every day I was just a
myth I was a zombie I was so tired
Thursday
the last day was the worst day I've ever
happy we went on a boat party it was I
forgot about that
I wasn't most while I know you were not
a boat party
I know if in so sick of my life and it
was how do I explain it first was the
boat was [ __ ] like I was in captivity it
wasn't a boat why it felt like captain
Phillips
that's what I felt like I'm captain now
that's what I felt like me all it needed
was a cop and Somalian pirates to be
like I'm captain now it was mad it was
atrocious and we yeah so I remember we
walked up to the dock or whatever and
there was a luxurious boat there but
there was just Chinese families all
lined up and I was thinking this can't
be I want this to be the boy Pike as the
boat looks buff but the populace it the
clientele is not I'm looking for in
horrified it's just loads of Chinese
families yeah and then they got on and
I'm like alright cool so it's not our
pie and then
our rickety-ass boat rocks up and I'm
like alright man
let's just let's just do it and I didn't
know what I expected in terms of what
the because I've never been on a boat
before I don't know why I expected in
terms of what like the deck or would be
I'd in my head it was like this is this
is a way over the top but in my head it
was like we've got like up there's a
pool in there and there's always a yacht
party basically long story showing
better we thought was a yacht party not
a berry pie a [ __ ] yacht pie that's
what we thought it was gonna be
that's exactly what you're trying to
explain [ __ ] luxurious that's what I
find in the SS Minnow Johnson my art is
your yard this is your job that's what I
wanted from the SS Minnow and brav
rocked up and I did I can't describe how
whack this boat was but it was just like
a normal boat yeah it was just chairs
like seats ease there wasn't a bar there
was just a lady at a table with plastic
cups and like a jug of orange juice and
a bottle of vodka made and then I'm like
okay there was a [ __ ] chick with a
tampon string hanging out of her eggs
from Newcastle that made me gag I had to
go up to her and tell her and you know
define it's early so it's going up but
you know the funniest thing about that
when I approached her because she was
sat down and I walked up to her to like
talking her ear cuz was loud she falls
move into her sheep arm around me and
she fought I was moving to ours like
babes I need to tell you something she's
got what babes oh god what babes I'm not
gonna lie like this strings been hanging
out for the whole shebang the whole ting
I was dumbfounded cuz that's so
disgusting was dumbfounded she thought I
was about to meet her she was gay I just
had to tell her she needs to she needs
to wrap that thing up oh that's
disgusting that's disgusting
when funny when this is stupid when you
move away
you went to speak to her and you clocked
that she was game did you think [ __ ] I
wish I wish I was moving too you know
where she didn't have this tampon
hanging out your legs yes and now yes
for the wherein I be for [ __ ] yeah yeah
no because she wasn't she
I don't know she wasn't paying she
wasn't paying and I went about to
embarrass myself in front of 50 people I
don't even know do not mean no that's
why I said yes to know when you got
seasick that made my day
what I remembers you've been like
sluggish a bit delirious and you're like
I'm gonna vomit you came back with a
smile in your face and you were so brain
where I thought you've been in the water
you came back so I've never seen anyone
so wet who didn't just get out of a pool
I couldn't believe my [ __ ] eye the
vibrations in my face made me sweat I
was throwing the [ __ ] up I was throwing
the [ __ ] up I couldn't believe it I was
I would never go in a boat play again
after that experience I'll never go in a
boat play again oh that's [ __ ] the
worst thing of my life I nee worst thing
of my life that's [ __ ] funny
it was so [ __ ] he was so [ __ ] I wanted
the yacht pie in my head that's what he
was rung up are you mine it was just
yacht party and there was a dance floor
here there was a pool here there's bars
there's bars and then there's just
[ __ ] happy guys everyone's here that
means their space loads of space loads
of spin this crystal clear waters and
everyone's laughing oh that was what it
was in my head instead I just got the
CIM said the opposite of that and I also
had the worst hanger for my life yeah it
was [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and then we went
to ash wire we had no money left it was
the same day was the same day we went
straight from the boat party to the
hotel to get changed and as here we had
the wristband yeah yeah yeah
and all I wanted to do was go to sleep
same I didn't want to be spoken to I
didn't want to go out in my head I was
like brother give me a quick three our
kin and we will do whatever you guys
want to do whatever you want to do we'll
do it but we had to get in there and
stay there and stay there
yeah who's we had to get there before
like six or something ridiculous and
weird stay in there so then we walked
[ __ ] what felt like three miles to
get there got in there and stayed there
to like gone midnight standing in the
same my knees fat my joints had never
had so much my life my knees were in
bits when we sat down to get food oh
that's on that bench that was I feel
like if we went to shui unlike the first
or second I really had the best night I
would have been off for life it would
have been the best night it's a
fantastic place to go to you yes amazing
like the chick died saw and I would
never forget how beautiful she was
- why she was standing next on a look on
a lonesome he just was it kaya goat that
was the end yes yeah yeah yeah she was
entranced with it
neutrons with it and he set was amazing
to be fair was though I was so [ __ ]
sad but she was so beautiful I'd never
seen anything like him my beef is got
women women i beavers got women and
never seen anything in my life she was
so beautiful oh [ __ ] no good stories man
those stories right we've had memories
wrap it wrap it